interesting because whenever like i talk
to people about abortion they always um
make it seem like it's only used in like
chill but no not no no it's not chill
that it's only used in cases of
emergencies and like like
all that stuff but and my feeling is
that it's more used as a form of birth
control today rather than and it's
usually because there's some form of
irresponsibility so rather than like the
exceptions so that is very much so i was
a sexual health advisor for the largest
trust in the uk be passed through the
british pregnancy advisory service i
don't know the number one i don't know
every single person that i know that's
had an abortion
it was like just them being
irresponsible like it was literally just
them being like i don't know a single
person well i've in my time in my
position i'd only spoken to one girl who
was like
oh yeah i need an abortion but i used to
know the b pass number but off by heart
it's something like oh three hundred
three hundred eight hundred or o three
hundred eight hundred years oh i mean i
do it off by heart but the first woman i
ever spoke to an assistant in abortion
she was a married woman
she had two kids her oldest son was um
disabled
um she was like even my daughter that we
had was like an accident but a happy
accident and she was like she was
sobbing to me on the phone she was like
in her late 30s and she was like
something maybe say that's not really
like natural if we're like sobbing like
like if that's your reaction to it yeah
yeah no no no but then i was like you
don't need to explain yourself to me i
was like it's not my business i was like
it's not my business not my opinion i
was like you like you've clearly had
like a nice night with your husband your
family like you've got a lot of [ __ ]
going on and i was like it's not my
business i was like abortion get an
abortion yeah but then i've also spoken
to
some women who are like
really chill like hey i need an abortion
as if it's birth control yeah and
they're like
honey like that's
just just go just go on
you know you know my mom was in a
position where she like
like most people would have advised her
to get an abortion because she was 17
and she got pregnant
but um by my dad actually at the time
and they actually ended up like giving
up that kid for adoption and he like
he ended up being like a really
successful like sales software engineer
he just got married that's why i
actually have a really hard time
with it because i feel like if anyone
was going to get it it could have been
my mom like she was broke she was 17. so
this is very interesting um i studied
under professor roger ingram if he's
ever watching which he might not be so i
studied um psychology of sexual health
and we did um my personal project was
outcomes of teenage conception yeah and
it's proven all of the research and you
have to obviously look in the bias all
the research shows that it's more
harmful for the woman the better of that
child to have a child and give it up
than it is to have an abortion what do
you what what does that mean it's more
like so the woman for the rest of her
life will be like did i make the right
choice is my child okay rather than
being like i'm gonna have an abortion
and this is why and so i think i think a
lot of times like again we're making it
about us when it's really it's not about
you because there's a kid in the picture
yeah so you can't you can't you can't
you can't then but then it's like why is
that kid more important than you
why i mean i think in my mom's case like
he grew up to like have a really great
life yeah yeah like and so it's it kind
of like rubs me the wrong way we don't
use them i think i think that's like why
it rubs me wrong way the little bit when
people are like make it not a life
because like my brother grew up and like
yeah did all these like amazing yeah and
there's always going to be but this is
why so uh roger engram he's a professor
he's a professor he's like the best in
his field
um he so he literally told everyone he
was like we don't use the term pro-life
right to be pro-life you would have to
be a vegetarian a vegan you won't step
on an ant but you would care about that
woman yeah telling you i want an
abortion because i mean you're you're
either pro-choice or you're
anti-abortion you're not pro-life
because
i need you to clarify that so because
i step on ants yeah because
that doesn't really make sense so that's
well then you're not pro-life because
that's our life that's that's not a
human life
so then you're pro-human life but then
if you're pro-human but like i think
it's like easily implied like like
everyone everyone
you know okay okay let me just let me
just let me just ask you do you do you
think there's a difference between a
human life and an aunt yeah i do but
then it's still a life it's right but i
know but like you're just kind of trying
to get like a gotcha question like oh
it's clearly
everything
i want an abortion yeah
why is her life
less important
than that because i don't think just
because you have a kid your life is over
i also think i also think the argument
is that she's in that situation
because of the decisions that she's made
whereas
the consequence is happening to the
child
which is the only innocent party
arguably does that make sense but again
it's like if it's a ball of cells but
also okay what if she's on contraception
and she's taking this like it has a
unique dna sequence yeah like a very
like you can see but then
if she doesn't value it why is it
valuable to everyone else and then we go
on to adoption okay if these kids are
valuable why are we overrun in every
western community of like ch children
get that's it they get you so you think
the kids aren't valuable if they're poor
i think they're valuable but they're
clearly not being adopted by people who
are pro-life they're they are there my
parents are pro-life they adopted three
kids and you gave up one but that's but
that's just your personal experience
right there's a lot of people that want
to adopt like even now like yeah it's
like
but could you let me finish um sorry but
the problem is that like the legal
systems are aren't don't make it easy
yeah no no so a lot like there's
families that have been waiting for
years to adopt but like they want a baby
they don't want a kid that's been
waiting for years oh for sure that's i
mean i've seen like i've actually seen
the negative like consequences of
getting a kid that's too old it's really
hard to d like if you if you get them
past a certain age a lot of them come
with a lot of issues yeah like this is
it yeah professor washington all
i think ideally like it would be better
if the kids were adopted earlier rather
than like growing up in foster care
that's not good for any kid yeah but
then they don't get a choice in that
they don't get a say when they're born
that's just a decision made for them by
being forced to be born and there's a
lot of people who
will joke and be like i didn't ask to be
born so i was suicidal for three years
and i was like i didn't ask you to be
born and my mum will say to me my mom is
quite unwell at the moment my mom will
say to me i wish i would she's like i
wish i bought you yeah that's really sad
yeah but i know she doesn't mean it i
know she loves me but she's like i have
so much guilt and she was a mum who
carried us to term who looked after us
and she's like i still feel like i can't
provide for you and i'm like no i get it
i understand that you would
not have a lot of guilt you wouldn't
have a lot of like responsibilities like
expo said
um but um again it's like it's all to a
difference i understand that for a lot
of people they're successful stories for
a lot of people um but for myself
individually yeah it's just very i'm
very pro-choice yeah it's it's not black
ops it's just like almost like we focus
on like the negative stories rather than
the positive like even when me and you
talking about this now like your focus
immediately is well there's all these
kids in foster care that can't get
adopted rather than like the story i
just told you of the three like right
you know it's just weird how like that
that's your immediate focus rather like
there's both you know what i mean i i i
have a question just played devil's
advocate um do you
do you think there is any circumstance
where it is better for a human being not
to be born
than
to have a life no matter how much
suffering there is in it
oh that's really hot like let's talk
about ukraine right now like oh i'll
give you i'm giving him a better i'll
give you i'll give you a better example
let's talk about slavery
would you say it was better for
a child slave to not be born than to be
born and go through slavery but then
potentially have the chance for freedom
depending
that's really hard